hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space okay I was just
about to upgrade my equipment and I'm
gonna see what idea I got four nodes so
I'm always gonna keep one at least so I
want to upgrade this pulse rifle to
damage because I think I think if I do
it's gonna be like super worth it so I'm
gonna keep two and oh that hand is
losing his fingers and whatever not me
I'm stupid tough and smart don't trust
anyone anymore AB what is that
how come I didn't see that well those
are just suits okay it's okay
it just suits right um okay yeah go the
right way the head all right where am I
going now
oh what's that
you want some bullets I got plenty for
you give me um dum dum ripper what is a
ripper remote Industrials saw
you know what I haven't I haven't bought
a weapon I've got credit stockpiling so
I'm gonna go for it
help probably useful huh Ripper is a
ripper ammo is a no ammo gun that's
great I just see what we got here Ripper
Ripper there we go okay okay
bullets oh oh look at that
oh hell yeah oh I'm so gonna cut people
up oh my goodness gravy I'm gonna rip
people apart just as soon as I say Bing
bong oh this is gonna be great
or it's not gonna be great I probably
just think it's great but whatever seems
great over here nothing lockdoor okay
going down the elevator oh bring it
bring it on I'm ready for anything
you like my setup here I'm playing in
complete darkness and it's like 12:30 at
night this is an headphones on so I'm
immersing myself in the work hey I got a
saw and Tory decontamination all right I
don't mess with me I got a saw
gimme gimme I don't things give to me
yeah med care this is tell you now the
centrifuge is offline uh-huh we've got
four trillion tons of rock hanging off
our ass room without that centrifuge I
balanced the ship the gravity tethers
will call it straight down to the colony
yeah that seems I'm hanging in there now
dad I can fix it yeah I'm an engineer I
don't I don't know what the hell you're
talking about
I picked something up huh
beds I don't need you bench you need to
hold on to my power thingies decon
chamber okay ah what oh [ __ ] oh that was
a bad idea
[ __ ] you [ __ ] oh I got a saw so ready
for you bring it up bring it on bring it
on oh oh oh put that you can't get in a
few I'm [ __ ] there are vents everywhere
oh [ __ ] they're events okay um oh no
there's only one bed okay bring it on
nope
oh I'll go get me hi hi hey hey hey hi
hi yeah yeah Oh got you apart oh yeah I
love this get dead
hi Oh what yeah nothin
Hey good up cutting you apart
okay well that didn't work exposing oh I
hey no no no come on there we go
Oh to pieces all right okay is that
everything yeah let me through all [ __ ]
out all you yeah you're okay
contamination sequence your feet thank
you for your patience
you're welcome madam probably another
one of those computer voices that are
gonna add I don't want to kick your run
that's gonna like start saying weird
stuff to me after a while like
intentionally nagging me
who's out there Oh big hallway what was
that probably nothing I chose probably
something big hallway ooh
power new-money yeah is that that it's
like creep whatever
okay got a power node saw some goop Vlad
goop
so now the mother's behold Oh what
happened this guy I don't really care
because there's au n natori full what
the heck
okay I don't need air I do not need air
why do I have hair
get out of here here no I do not want
you air gold semiconductor okay all
right back off got a saw
who's out there this is more air I don't
need air why are you giving me air
buncha Maroons okay zero gravity
I like that gimme gimme pulse so smart
ooh
oh it's pulsating you that is grody
Blair Blair Blair Blair look at all that
any other items flowing around probably
probably what am I doing here am i doing
oh oh you are getting the other guns cuz
I can't reach what's that what's that
all dead
Hey nope nope Hey
nope nope no gone Oh
donate a try buddy I'm Way too skilled
for you I need to use I need to use one
of my healthy that'll clear up some
space
all right how we doing today okay
Wow what'd I do
what do I do what am i doing I didn't
see anything to do anything
oh it's zero gravity I can jump around
right okay no no there we go okay
what are these big old things
this was a move
you stasis okay thank you for the him
hi hi ah what is that was that go it
[ __ ] [ __ ] to shotted to shotted yeah
here funk
there goes your head okay
look at me go I run so stupidly doing it
don't do doing okay you stay sister slow
objects oh wow is that so great oh hey
hi re are home one two gone
alright alright no one up there I see it
stasis recharge dummy dummy good walkie
ah damn it get there we go okay
man that is unintuitive okay
all right full up on stasis well so I
did is that huh
oh guy why are you still bleeding you
should have stopped bleeding a long time
ago buddy all right
I did something um oh here we go um oh I
can press the control button to get that
girl okay
oh that's why I needed air Oh stupid me
Oh government of all the year got rid of
all year okay whoa hey what is that
looks like something that would smash me
huh not not this time buddy
Oh get out of here you're doing great
Isaac hey I'm in him I need a run oh no
no no no no no aah aah you [ __ ] you
asked who you talk to me right as I need
to run you shut up I when I find you if
you're not dead by the time I find you
I'm gonna kill you CUDA Marco
okay oh I don't need to save so much I
can just see Otto says okay that's good
it's funny okay so I'm gonna quit you
know I can't wait I don't have any air
gonna run out of air
maybe I don't know I don't know is there
an air thing nobody can I stasis that
damn it I missed okay
oh you're doing great Isaac fu huge
ingeras are both 100% and stabilized oh
yeah yeah focus on the engine
ya know how much time we have left I
don't have much time left
alright um there's an alcove right there
I think I can make it ah ha okay made it
ah gonna bomb bang e bang boom gone okay
ah running out of here
what again air oh oh show mercy okay go
go go go go the plan I missed it I can't
go back alright
Oh an oxygen Richard okay I can't go
back to this I probably shouldn't but
here I go anyway durpa durpa durpa gimme
okay and then so what is that thing a
gravity centrifuge cuz that makes sense
I'm sure that's scientifically sound
okay
we go go go go no do not [ __ ] with me
bro Oh get some one shot Oh
pwned I like this guy screams he sounds
manly okay one more block oh uh elevator
okay
oh so pro so
Oh No I'm running out of air Oh durp a
durp a durp now I'm not even close oh
I'm so pro okay I'll take this um image
or something please okay well lock it
okay
they just save here or I could go into
doink and I will cut it here thank you
guys so much for watching as always I
appreciate all of you so thanks for
watching and I will see you in the next
video bye bye